thanks to nebula for sponsoring this
video space is a modern Fascination
these days you're barely even a
billionaire if you don't send phallic
objects hurtling into the final frontier
but space is not a modern invention
ancient people knew that up there is
fundamentally different to down here
anyone who lived near a mountain could
have told you that things got colder as
you got higher up there the air is thin
and it's cold it stood to reason that
the higher you went the thinner and
colder the air got eventually there must
be an outer space that was very
different to here on the surface the
most influential ancient thinker on this
subject was professional wrong opinion
however Aristotle who divided the
universe into concentric spheres of the
classical elements earth water air and
fire so stuff that happened over our
heads could be divided into the study of
stuff that happened in the sphere of air
meteorology and stuff that happened in
the sphere of fire astronomy this is
where we get the name for the modern
field of meteorology from so Aristotle
depicted there being a definite boundary
between the atmosphere and outer space
space and so a definite height above the
Earth at which this boundary occurs
today we know that there isn't really
such a thing as a definite Edge to space
the atmosphere just Peters out and there
are several Heights you could claim as
the top of the atmosphere the most
common being the Carmen line which is
100 km up partly because it's a nice
round number I made a whole video about
this previously but while we think of
Science and specifically atmospheric
science as coming from this long
unbroken line of the ancient Greeks to
Renaissance Europe to the modern Western
World the reality is much more complex
and much more interesting important
contributions were made Elsewhere for
example the first estimate of that
Aristotle inspired height of the
atmosphere where outer space begins was
made by a man called Ian muad aljani we
don't know very much about iban muad we
know that he was a scholar and judge
living in andalia modern day Spain we
know that he was alive for a solar
eclipse in
1087 and wow we really don't know much
but we do have a bunch of writings by
him on on mathematics and specifically
spherical geometry that went on to be
quite influential on mathematicians in
both the Western and Arab worlds one of
his Works detailed an experiment you can
do to estimate the height of the
atmosphere it just involved some simple
geometry and two simple measurements
that I can take right
[Music]
now this is the Western roundhill on the
outskirts of bath and I'm here because
it makes the video more interesting but
it also has some of the best views in
the entire city which is really saying
something more specifically than that
it's going to give me a great view
of the
sunet so the sun has just set I only
make that
4:31 p.m. now all I've got to do is uh
wait to explain why I needed to wait I
made this model of the earth so we've
got the planet and the atmosphere and
I've exaggerated the height of the
atmosphere for the sake of this diagram
and let's say we're up here at the top
so we can draw a line to represent our
horizon line anything above this line we
can see anything below we can't for
example if the Sun is above this line
then we can see it and it can also
illuminate the atmosphere above us this
is daytime but if the Earth spins on its
axis and the sun dips below the Horizon
here it can no longer be seen by us at
the surface the sun sets but while we
can't see the Sun at the surface the
atmosphere above us is still being
illuminated by its Rays this is why the
sky doesn't immediately darken when the
sun sets instead we go from daytime to
Twilight Twilight lasts until the Earth
has spun on its axis a little further
and the top of the atmosphere visible to
us up here here is no longer being
illuminated by the sun's Rays remember I
have exaggerated the size of the
atmosphere for this diagram when the Sun
reaches this point which is the sunset
from the perspective of the top of the
atmosphere visible to us then the sky
above us is entirely dark exit light
enter night now let me add two more
lines from the center of the earth to us
as the Observer on top of the earth and
from the center of the earth to this
point I mad realized that the angle
between these two lines can be found by
timing how long it took for the sun to
move from this position to this position
in other words from Sunset to the end of
Twilight we can do that because we know
the sun travels through 360° in 24 hours
so in say 1 hour it travels through 360
/ 24 15° if we know this angle angle and
we know the radius of the Earth which
Scholars have had estimates of for
thousands of years then we can do some
trigonometry to calculate this extra
height here all I had to do was wait
until Twilight had finished and he
leaned down to press his cold lips once
more to my
throat okay this is very imprecise but I
can certainly say that the sky behind me
is completely dark the sky above me is
definitely dark over where the sun's set
I've watched the light dim and dim
there's maybe a thin amount of Light by
The Horizon but I'm getting cold uh and
I'm happy to say that that is the end of
Twilight so by my
watch that's 549 p.m. approximately I
mean it's dark enough to see the stars
so I think we can we can claim that
that's the end of Twilight look you can
even actually see the names of my
executive producer patrons over on
patreon.com ox
fiz Nature's amazing isn't it okay so we
have our two times Sunset happened at
4:31 and Twilight ended at
549 that means that Twilight lasted
78 minutes and I can tell you that in
that time the sun traveled through 19.5
de now comes the cool bit let me add
another line I'm going to split this
angle in half a line from here to the
top of the atmosphere that gives us a
right angle triangle this angle up here
is a right angle it's perpendicular to
the radius on one side of the right
angle triangle we have the radius of the
Earth let's call it R and on the other
side of the right angle triangle we have
the radius of the Earth plus the height
of the atmosphere so let's call that r +
H the angle between those two lines is
then 19.5 / 2 so this angle here is is
9.75 de. because this is a right angled
triangle we can then Define the coine of
this angle let's just call it X say as
the length of
the adjacent side R over the length of
the hypotenuse which is r + H so we know
what the radius of the Earth is it's
about 6,400 km and we know what this
angle X is 9.75 De so let's rearrange
this equation to find H the height of
the
atmosphere so using R =
6,371 km and x equal
9.75 de we find a value of the height of
the atmosphere of
93 km which if you recall the Caron line
which is the common boundary for space
that we use today is 100
km I'm pretty happy with that how does
that compare to IB muad though he
calculated that the sun traveled through
18° during Twilight and so using his
value of the radius of the Earth that
meant that the height of the atmosphere
was 84 km or 52 mil so I'm pretty close
of course however this is a flawed
method of calculating the height of the
atmosphere for one thing it doesn't
account for the effect of atmospheric
refraction something that was only added
centuries later by Tao brah I'm also not
sure how Ian muad handled the effect of
the latitude of the Observer on the
calculation because I don't have access
to the original and even if I did I
wouldn't be able to read it because it's
an Arabic but there's also the fact that
there is no edge of space trying to
assign one number for the height of the
atmosphere where space begins inherently
involves an arbitrary choice but
somewhere between about 80 km and about
200 km above the surface the atmosphere
stops behaving like the atmosphere that
we know and so as well as being
ingenious I think imad's estimate is
fine it neatly demonstrates that not all
atmospheric science is modern it's
actually one of the oldest of the
sciences and it's certainly not all
Western both things I'd like to point
out you can read more about in my book
on the history of atmospheric science
firmament but more than that I think
it's a wonderful demonstration that with
just two observations and a little bit
of clever thinking and you can discover
something new about the world around you
that you couldn't possibly have known
before and that to me that is the magic
of science I don't know if you can see
it behind me but that there is the
constellation Orion the Hunter and did
you know that below the three stars of
the Bell there's three stars of his
Scabbard except the Middle star in the
Scabbard isn't a star at all sorry it
was tooold out there it's a nebula a
nebula that you can see with the naked
eye the Orion Nebula nebula are the
Stellar nurseries of the universe
they're these places where brilliant new
stars are made and that's also true of
this episode's sponsor also called
nebula now I'm going to put my cards on
the table I am part of the group of
creators that created and manage nebula
we built it as a place to post our
videos away from advertisers there are
no adver in videos on nebula and away
from the YouTube algorithm a place we
could experiment cover topics that might
risk demonetization and post content we
were passionate about but would never
perform on YouTube for example along
with a whole raft of other original
videos I've posted an analysis of the
carbon footprint of a well-known adult
streaming site on nebula that would
never have flown on YouTube I also
wouldn't have been able to produce a
whole series on how I write and produce
videos like this one without funding
from nebula turning data into stories is
available on nebula classes right now by
getting yourself a subscription to
nebula you do three things firstly you
give yourself access to a huge library
of content that's either exclusive to
nebula or is available there before
anywhere else secondly you support the
evolution of independent online
educational video and thirdly you
directly support creators like me if you
like my videos and you'd like me to make
more of them then signing up to nebula
is one of the very best ways that you
can make that happen you can sign up at
go.
nebula.com Clark which will be in the
description with thanks to nebula for
sponsoring this video thank you for
watching the video I really enjoyed
putting this one together perhaps
unsurprisingly given that I wrote a book
on this stuff if you'd like to see me
make more videos about this history side
of things then do let me know down in
the comments if you enjoyed the video
please do the YouTube pleasantries pop
it a like share the video with people
that you think may enjoy it and if you'd
like a recommendation of what to view
next then here's two videos I prepared
earlier that just leaves me to say thank
you again for watching and I'll see you
in the next one